así
gracias por seguir aquí sé que esta
discusión se está volviendo un poco
técnica pero finalmente tenemos todas
las herramientas que necesitamos para
terminar la deducción de una fórmula
para el punto de intersección en una
parábola pero antes de continuar
regresemos un poco y recordemos por qué
estamos haciendo esto
bueno necesitamos la fórmula del punto
de intersección para que se las como
está en valiente puedan ser
computarizadas de manera eficiente
porque ese punto de encuentro nos
permitirá escribir programas de
computadora para dibujar cada hoja de
pasto sin tener que dibujar todas las
líneas de construcción individuales
entonces para convertir esto en fórmulas
nuevamente etiquetemos las cosas esta
línea de color rosa es controlada por el
parámetro temp
entonces voy a etiquetarlos como antes
este es el punto q10 es el punto r la
línea morada es controlada por el
parámetro es el entonces a este punto lo
voy a llamar prima y a este punto ere
prima ahora empecemos a escribir algunas
cosas que ya sabemos sabemos qué q es
una fracción de tema a lo largo del
segmento ave lo que significa que puedo
escribir a kun como uno menos por a más
de por b y de forma similar r es una
fracción de t a lo largo del segmento b
c así que podemos escribir a eren como
1 - de volver más de porce de manera
similar tu prima es una fracción de s a
lo largo del segmento ab entonces puedo
escribir a tu prima como 1 - ese
programa + s por b y finalmente puedo
escribir a r prima como 1 - s por ver
más ese por c ok ahora este punto de
intersección que es el que buscamos
llamado p se encuentra en algún lugar
del segmento de la línea r pero en qué
parte del segmento está bueno pues en un
segundo probar en que es una fracción de
ese entonces yo digo que p se puede
escribir como 1 - s por q mas s por r
ahora si esto es verdad algo bueno
sucede porque conforme se acerca te esta
expresión de aquí se acerca a uno
por q mas t por er y eso es lo que
finalmente quiero probar entonces lo
único que nos queda por mostrar es que
el punto de intersección se puede
escribir de esta manera y porque sería
ese el caso bueno pues lo que haremos es
que voy a sustituir esta expresión de
cuba aquí y esta expresión de aquí y
después si hago eso y lo reordenó es más
dejaré que ustedes lo reordenen pero les
adelanto que el resultado es que p se
puede escribir como uno menos este por 1
- usted por a más s por 1 - tema más t
que multiplica a uno menos s todo esto
por de más
por tema que multiplica hace y ahora si
le escribo todo esto usando las
expresiones para q prima jerry prima veo
que puedo escribir ap como 1 - temp por
q priman más de por ere prima y bueno
esta expresión nos dice que p se
encuentra en algún lugar del segmento de
la línea q prima prima y esta expresión
nos dice que p se encuentra en algún
lugar en el segmento de la línea qr así
que el único punto en el que coinciden
los dos segmentos es el punto de
intersección y entonces nuestra prueba
está completa
justo en el blanco